[Musique]
ce soir je vais vous parler de l'un des
plus gros scandales scientifique de ces
100 dernières années au moins pour vous
puissiez prendre la mesure de ce
scandale
je vais commencer par vous montrer trois
photos la première photo voici
il s'agit d'un trou noir
le trou noir est l'un des objets
astrophysiques les plus fascinants mais
peut-être aussi les plus inquiétants des
plus effrayants de l'univers tout ce qui
tombe dedans et piéger à jamais la
lumière elle même ne peut en sortir
donc qui nous semblent noir obscur sont
moins leur existence a été prédite par
la théorie d'einstein en 1915 à peu près
100 ans
au début personne n'y croyait vraiment
et aujourd'hui on sait qu'il en existe
dans le centre de quasiment toutes les
galaxies de l'univers
ceux qui à l'intérieur personne ne sait
personne n'y a été voir je vous
déconseille d'aller faire un tour et
aucune théorie n'est aujourd'hui en
mesure d'expliquer ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur des trous noirs
la deuxième photo vous voyez cette photo
là représentent un phénomène qui n'a
rien à voir avec le précédent
bon les esprits les plus éclairés auront
vu des petites ressemblance mais cette
fois ci il s'agit d'un morceau de
matière noire
la matière noire on l'appelle ainsi
parce que on sait pas ce que c'est on
n'a pas trouvé d'autres non on ne la
sent pas on ne la voit pas ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on pense avoir c'est qu'on en
trouve dans quasiment toutes les
galaxies
comment en regardant la façon dont les
galaxies tournent les galaxies
aujourd'hui tourne tellement vite dans
l'univers qu'elle devrait se disloquer
prenez un bol de soupe une assiette de
soupe faite à tourner sur votre table
encore plus vite
vous allez vite imaginé que bon vous
aurez un truc qui ressemble à une
galaxie pas trop
mais la soupe va en quelque sorte se
disloquait c'est pareil on devrait
observer la même chose sur les galaxies
mais on voit qu'elle existe un soldat
alors les physiciens ont supposé qu'il
existe une forme de matière la matière
noire qui hélas un peu pour coller les
éléments de la galaxie grâce à
l'interaction gravitationnelle et
l'empêché de se disloquer
cette matière noire selon nos calculs
aujourd'hui représenterait 25% du
contenu de l'univers troisième photo la
troisième photo vous êtes maintenant des
grands experts d'astro et de cosmologie
vous reconnaîtrez ici
l'énergie noire l'énergie noire
on en trouve un peu partout dans
l'univers ici dans un amas de galaxies
et l'énergie noire tout comme son copain
la matière noire
on l'appelle ainsi parce que on sait pas
ce que c'est on ne la voit pas on ne la
sent pas comment on pense savoir qu'il y
a de l'énergie noire parce qu'il ya 20
ans on s'est aperçu que l'univers
grossistes et de plus en plus vite
si l'univers est un ballon de baudruche
imaginez que quelqu'un souffle dedans de
plus en plus fort pour le faire grossir
de plus en plus vite dans cette image ce
quelqu'un qu'elles sucent de l'énergie
c'est précisément ça qu'on appelle
l'énergie noire évidemment il a personne
au bout de l'univers
peut-être que oui mais moi je n'ai pas
encore vu il ya personne qui pousse
l'univers mais aujourd'hui on le voit
grossir de plus en plus vite et donc on
suppose qu'il existe une forme d'énergie
qui va être énergie noire
selon nos calculs l'énergie noire forme
70 % du contenu de l'univers
alors faisons un petit bilan
on arrive dans une situation où
finalement le modèle d'univers c'est
celui ci le petit carré dans là haut
c'est ce que vous connaissez les
galaxies les planètes à l'intérieur les
étoiles il ya même les trous noirs comme
est là parce qu'on sait à peu près ce
qu'ils sont même si on sait pas trop ce
qu à l'intérieur tout le reste 25 % de
matière noire 70%
énergie noire pour arriver à une
situation où 95%
on sait pas ce que c'est je sais pas si
vous avez conscience des moyens de
l'énergie que l'on met pour aller
comprendre ce qui se passe dans
l'univers les moyens c'est quoi si les
dizaines de milliers de chercheurs qui
bossent des centaines de milliers
d'heures dans les labos dans les
observatoires qui utilisent les outils
des plus puissants les plus
sophistiquées que l'homme n'a jamais
construit accélérateur de particules un
détecteur d'ondés gravitationnelles des
satellites qu'on envoie dans le ciel
pour envoyer plein de télescopes à voir
des images du ciel tout ça tout ça pour
arriver à la situation où la 95% de
l'univers désolé on sait pas ce que
c'est quelle société qui accepterait ça
qu'ils accepteraient autant de moyens
pour ce résultat là alors on va voir les
chercheurs on leur demande mais c'est
parce qu elle aille je sais pas c'est
dur c'est loin l'univers tout ça on n'y
arrive pas c'est pas comme si on
cherchait une aiguille dans une botte de
foin là c'est la bo de foin qu'on
cherche carrément alors
une fois qu'on a fait ce constat il faut
essayer d'aller de l'avant
je suis physicien théoricien avec mes
collègues et collaborateurs dispatcher
un peu partout dans le monde on élabore
des théories pour essayer de rendre
compte de la nature et de l'existence de
l'énergie noire ce soir je suis pas peu
fier de vous montrer le résultat est le
fruit de nos dernières découvertes et je
suis sûr que vous allez voir avec moi
derrière cette équation les secrets de
l'énergie noire et de la matière noire
cachez votre enthousiasme c'est vrai
mais c'est dingue c'est dingue tout ce
qu'on peut voir derrière cette équation
là nous on y voit beaucoup de choses à
mon avis une équation de ce type est pas
loin d'être très proche d'un tableau de
maître van gogh la nuit étoilée
si vous avez jamais vus stable à je peux
me risque à le décrire un arbre dans la
pénombre second plan un village sous un
ciel un petit peu à la façon d'un god un
peu tourmentée des étoiles est un clair
de lune
si je commence à vous le décrire vous
allez certainement visualiser le tableau
éventuellement comprendre ce que van
gogh a voulu dire à travers ce tableau
là mais si vous allez au musée et que
vous voyez la nuit étoilée l'émotion
ressentie sera sans commune mesure
une équation c'est peut-être la même
chose je vous montre une équation je
peux essayer de la verbaliser de vous
dire ce qu'il ya derrière ce qu'elle
signifie si je suis assez bon vous allez
peut-être percevoir deux ou trois trucs
qui vont vous éclairer sur la nature de
l'énergie noire mais si vous lisez
l'équation dans le langage mathématique
si vous la visualiser en quelque sorte
je vous garantis aussi que d'émotions et
la satisfaction intellectuelle vous
allez ressentir sera également sans
commune mesure
à ce titre certaines équations de la
physique
donc vous avez entendu parler l'équation
d'einstein pour l'infiniment grand
où l'équation de schrödinger pour
l'infiniment petit songes considérés
comme de véritables chefs-d'oeuvre de la
physique alors mon équation par notre
équation mes collègues avec
je sais pas si elle a la beauté de
l'équation d'einstein franchement je le
crois pas et honnêtement on n'est pas
encore complètement convaincu que va
nous éclairer sur l'énergie noire alors
alors on va peut-être évité de d'en
rajouter un petit peu plus en plus
sérieux au début quand j'ai présenté
quand j'ai préparé ce toc je me suis pas
d'équation pas d'équation mais je
travaille tous les jours avec et j'ai
pas résisté à la tentation de vous
montrer au moins celle ci je me suis dit
aussi
mais pourquoi leur parler d'énergie
noire de matière noire
finalement la seule chose qu'on
connaisse ce sont ces belles images que
je démontre au début on n'a aucune
certitude sur ce que son énergie et
matière noire que des hypothèses que des
doutes alors au fond peut-être qu'on
paie c'est de prendre un petit peu de
recul sur ces questions là et que la
bonne question à poser c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'y arrive pas malgré tout
les moyens qu'on se donne et pourquoi ce
n'est pas un scandale bien le contraire
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'y arrive
pas la réponse cette fois ci je peux
vous la donner et limpide
c'est juste parce que c'est difficile
c'est fichtrement difficile donc on n'y
arrive pas mais ce n'est pas parce que
c'est difficile et que la situation
allait rassure d'à priori qu'il faut se
démotiver et abandonner la question bien
au contraire et c'est là qu'on touche
le thème de ce soir l'utopie du
physicien l'utopie les physiciens c'est
celle de croire qu'on se dote des outils
qui vont nous permettre de répondre à
toutes les questions qui nous entoure et
franchement c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle j'ai fait de la physique cette
envie peut-être de comprendre un petit
peu tout ce qui m'entoure
mais en même temps on sait très bien que
plus on connaîtra plus ce sera difficile
de savoir plus parce qu'à la fin des
questions qui restent ce sont toujours
les questions les plus difficiles et
dans ce cas là il va falloir redoubler
d'imagination
il va falloir trouver les idées les plus
farfelues
certains diront les plus
révolutionnaires pour d'autres
construire des instruments encore plus
fort encore plus sophistiquée encore
plus puissant pour aller dénicher la
solution quelque part entre l'infiniment
grand et l'infiniment petit
alors ce problème de l'énergie noire et
de la matière noire sont très belle
histoire pour illustrer ce fait il ya
cent ans
quand l'instinct est arrivé avec sa
théorie on pensait avoir sous la main
les outils qui nous permettrait d'aller
sonder tous les coins et tous les
recoins de l'univers et puis la paf
arrive énergie noire et matière noire et
là on sait plus l'outil dont on pensait
pouvoir tout extraire ne marche plus
très bien on n'arrive plus vraiment à
lui faire dire ce qu'on ce qu'on
voudrait lui faire dire mais ce n'est
pas grave parce que dans l'histoire d'un
physique on a eu plein de moments comme
ceux-ci ou en pensez avoir des théories
au 19e siècle par exemple qui
permettrait de tout savoir sur tout le
monde sur vous sur moi sur ce qu'on a
été dans le passé
est ce qu'on sera dans le futur mais
tout et puis rester des petits détails
par ci par là à comprendre
et ces petits détails se sont avérées de
véritable cataclysme
tout était russe s'est effondré on a
reconstruit dessus et c'est ainsi que
sont nés la mécanique quantique pour
l'infiniment petit ainsi que la
relativité générale pour l'infiniment
grand
je ne sais pas si le problème de la de
la matière noire ou de l'énergie noire
vont aboutir à des révolutions aussi
cataclysmique
mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on va tout
faire pour y arriver mais on sait aussi
que on veut s'approcher d'une forme de
vérité absolue
la vérité scientifique la vérité tous
les jours certainement
c'est un concept asymptotique plus aussi
approche plus il est difficile d'accéder
vers elle c'est un peu tomber l'histoire
le paradoxe d'achille et la tortue
achille vous connaissez tous le
personnage de la mythologie grecque la
tortue c'est la tortue achille
par en retard dans sa course derrière la
tortue il est confiant au bout de
quelque part il voit l'animal en ligne
de mire se dit aucun problème il avance
il avance à chaque fois il reste une
distance certes petit certes de plus en
plus petit mais une distance qui est
toujours là pour attraper la tortue puis
il avance plus les jambes sont lourdes
le sol se dérobe comme du sable mouvant
l'histoire raconte cash il ne rattrapera
jamais la tortue le physicien de ces le
scientifique de ces il connaît très très
bien le sentiment d'achille derrière la
tortue mais il continue il avance parce
que ils rêvent de découvrir des nouveaux
mondes et au fond en physique en
sciences en avance par petits pas
quelquefois on fait des bonds de géant
parfois on recule fait marche arrière
peut-être pour prendre de l'élan
d'autres fois on avance et puis là on se
trouve face à un précipices vertigineux
l'énergie noire peut être un problème
incommensurable paris n'est pas le droit
de dépasser
la scala soit je saute sur le public
soit on essaie de construire de
nouvelles routes de nouveaux ponts qui
vont nous permettre d'accéder de l'autre
côté de la rive est souvent histoire
racontant ses ponts qui ont été
construits par un seul homme
on retient on parle souvent de lui ce
soir einstein un chien n'a construit
cassiman ses propres droits des
nouvelles routes qui nous ont permis de
sonder au sens propre comme au sens
figuré
tous les coins et recoins de l'univers
on est parti très très loin avec la
théorie d'einstein
mais très souvent la construction d'un
pont scientifique est une oeuvre
collective chacun vient il dépose une
brique ou quelqu'un d'autre un l'aide
d'une brique était cassée qui ne
marchait pas bien d'un autre va ajouter
de ciment et au final on arrive à des
édifices qui sont formidables qui sont
merveilleux alors peut-être que dans un
10 20 30 ou 100 ans
l'un de vous dans un an sera là et
expliquera comment il a réussi à
construire un pont vers le vaccin contre
le sida verts on a parlé ce soir
le problème du réchauffement climatique
vers une solution contre la pauvreté
dans le monde vers la conquête de la
planète mars ou quelqu'un sera là et
nous dira ce qu'est l'énergie noire
si aujourd'hui je suis je suis physicien
je dois beaucoup à la curiosité que
beaucoup de mes enseignants mon
entourage ont nourri au plus profond de
moi-même vouloir savoir et savoir est
une source d'inspiration infinie mais ça
ça ne suffit pas il faut aussi accepter
ne pas savoir il faut accepter atteindre
ses limites
mais cette forme d'ignorance ne doit pas
être une source de frustration ou
d'aigreur
elle doit être une source de motivation
ok on connaît 5% de l'univers mais il
reste 95 % à explorer allons-y t'aide à
mi-peine fusée à notre disposition on
touche on s'envole vers l'énergie noire
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]